rainfall, with the potential
for flash flooding across the
region.
We'll keep a close eye on this,
max.
Back to you.
>> Okay, thank you to Derek.
It's just after 11 am in Greece,
where crews are searching for
survivors after terrific train
wreck.
So far, more than three dozen
people are confirmed dead after
passing a train collided with a
freight train near the city of
laryssa.
We learned moments ago that
they were apparently traveling
on the same track for quite
awhile as well.
Authorities are trying to
identify the victims.
CNN's Eleni giokos tracking
this live for us from dubai.
Eleni, first of all, what do we
know about what happened here?
I mean, it's very powerful for
the pictures how bad it is.
>> It is bad.
And you have a cargo train
traveling from thessaloniki,
and the passenger train
traveling from Athens but, head
on collision.
The first two carriages
catching a light.
And you can see the devastation,
mangled metal.
You've got crane and you've got
metal cutting machinery to try
and cut through those two first
carriages.
And that's the fear, that more
people are trapped.
And the death toll rising now
2:38.
When I was last on air, it was
36.
You've got 66 people that are
injured.
Seven of whom are currently in
intensive care.
You're seeing lines of people
in Larissa waiting to donate
blood.
So, the big question is, what
happened here?
How did they collide?
The national broadcaster
reporting that at some point,
the passenger train changed
lanes and was traveling for
quite some time on the same
line as the cargo train.
And then of course, that
resulted in a collision.
The question is, is it a
technical fault?
Is it a human error?
Who is going to be taking
responsibility for this?
Investigations are currently
underway.
We know that the prime minister,
Mia talk is, is underway to the
press area.
But in the meantime, what we're
hearing from the hospital is
that parents family loved ones
people traveling on the train
have gathered to try and
identify the dead.
The dish --
the issue is it's difficult
from what we hear from
authorities to identify the
people, because the injuries
were absolutely so severe.
We've also heard reports from
some passengers that they were
being thrown around in the
carriages.
Also, as the fire broke out,
some people were burned.
So, we're talking about a very
traumatic severe experience.
And as we go through the search
and rescue, it's almost 12
hours since the accident
occurred.
You're seeing major response
from the international
communities, specifically
Europeans.
European commissioner coming
out and extending condolences.
So to the eu council president
as well, various countries in
Europe.
But in the meantime, Greeks are
waiting to see how this